- Who's most likely to be found
at the bottom of the L.A. River?
(funky music)
- [Joel] Dirk.
- [Dirk] Me.
- Dirk.
- Cruising the craft table.
- They actually put my chair
up right by the craft table.
(funky music)
- [Melissa] The ladies.
- The three down in the front.
- The ladies generally, yeah.
- [Joe] Yeah.
- Yeah, I know, the guys
show up two hours later
than we do.
- Yeah, because patriarchy.
(funky music)
- Terry.
- [Melissa] Terry.
- Probably me, oh, and Terry.
(laughter)
(funky music)
- This set is a prank sanctuary.
(laughter)
If she ain't pranking
us, she's pranking us.
If she ain't pranking us,
these guys are pranking us.
It's just an all day thing. Pranks.
- We're prankophiles.
- We're prankophiles, that's our thing.
Dirk went a little too far.
He set the whole set on
fire. We had to rebuild it.
- [Stephanie] Yeah, that was unfortunate.
- It was an accident.
- [Joe] That was not good.
- So that was intense.
(funky music)
- God, I've fallen off
this season a little bit.
- (laughs) I mean, I would say,
I'd say season three, it's Chelsea.
(laughter)
It was me.
- Yeah, we shifted positions.
I started strong and then this season,
I've really started losing
it a lot more frequently.
(funky music)
Terry.
- [Melissa] Yeah.
- [Stephanie] Oh yeah.
- Married 25 years.
(funky music)
No one's annoying.
(laughter)
No one (laughs), we're all cool.
- It's a line we won't cross.